why oh I don't know if you guys are you
guys are not ready for this I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready for anything so like
the worst one is Taylor
Swift what's your oh you're saying
swifties are going to cancel us yeah oh
yeah you you don't want to feel the rat
of swifties yeah we don't but at the
same time speaker truth free
[Music]
thinker uh anybody here a fan of Madonna
Like A buron she got some you used to be
right no never never Ryan never you
bully sorry all right anyways she is
being sued over a late concert start by
fans Who quote had to get up early the
next morning you can get sue for that H
damn you can sue for that I think you
can sue for anything how late was she
yeah was it really late but it's like
isn't it fashionably late to for like
artists to always never be on time
especially rappers yeah cuz they need to
like smoke a whole joint in a b like a
pipe and a bong and a joint and and they
like to make people wait and take a nap
yeah and then they do their show like an
hour and a half after they're supposed
to start and then they and then they
have to show up and go y'all lucky I
even came yeah yeah the show was
advertised to start at 8:30 p.m. but the
65-year-old musician didn't take the
stage until after 10:30 that's too much
that's a I'm surprised she still able to
perform at that time at that age she
probably had dinner at 5:00 and then
took a nap and then that's when she was
ready to
go dude at 65 you guys think you guys
could Rock a concert at 10:30 p.m. cuz
right now I I'm just like I'm done
useless I can't even do that now right
right now in your youth yeah but we're
not getting paid Millions to do a tour
that's true yeah but if you're getting
Millions all the time what's another
million well if you've been spending
Millions all the time I I'll Just Fall
I'll just fall asleep on the millions I
think also it's like like did she just
like do part of her World Tour like
internationally and it's come back and
it's like jet lag time oh she's jet lag
I 2 hours is pretty crazy though isn't
it was there a show leading up to it and
like opening ax because then it's not
that bad usually okay so like opening
acts what hour right or two depends on
who the opening if there actually are
opening acts often times is like 2 hours
of like not until like you know if a
show starts at 8 yeah for sure you're
not going to see the Main Line headliner
until like 10: or 10:30 but that's crazy
when they don't come out and there's no
more acts it's just a DJ like playing
random stuff 2 hours of just silence
that'd be weird it's just a club pretty
much but except it's not hype yeah yeah
but this this is her tour I believe
though this wasn't like a so if she's 65
her fans are probably like late 50s
early 60s so maybe they were like
they're just grumpy pants yeah we got to
wake up at 5:00 a.m. dude how much are
they suing for it doesn't say uh and how
many people are actually attending her
concerts it was mainly two concert goers
that are like starting the lawsuit oh
two huh yeah they they said they left
after 1:00 a.m. which is maybe
perceivably normal um they were left
stranded in the middle of the night and
confronted with limited public
transportation limited ride sharing and
or increased public and private
transportation costs that's normal if
she started at 10:30 and they got out at
1 she actually went pretty hard that's a
good show that's a pretty good show
that's a banger show she almost made up
for it they said the late finish on the
week night show was also affected their
ability to quote take care of their
family responsibilities the next day
dude you went to the concert yeah don't
even go to the concert what the [__] go
home you could leave no one's putting a
gun in your head to stay at the concert
the suit is seeking class action status
for attenders of other celebration shows
which started late including Madonna's
next two concerts in New York wow so the
art class I guarantee you it was a
[__] old ass lawyer that was pissed
so then he got he turned it into a class
action lawsuit you can sue for anything
these days that's crazy that should be
you never know it'll pan out either cuz
remember those two guys that sued the
movie studio because they put Anna D
armis in a trailer for a movie she
wasn't in but they won they won that's
false advertisement though that is a
little bit but they won a lot of money
they didn't just win the movie ticket
they won a lot of money yeah Madonna
also faced similar lawsuits in 2019 when
a Florida fan argued her lateness on the
madb X Tour was in breach of contract
and then also in 20120 a lawsuit filed
by two New York concert goers and it
says both lawsuits were later
voluntarily dismissed which is maybe
like a shady little settlement hush
money you would think by 65 she has her
act together and can be on time but you
also think somebody that famous if they
maybe these people are already like oh
look they probably just settled for cash
on the side let's just [__] start the
lawsuit let's see what we can get I
always thought there was like some form
of immunity against this exact lawsuit
because it's so standard when you're
working with an artist that they want to
go on later it's like a thing where or
it kind of like builds the anticipation
up even more cuz they're like oh are
they here are they coming like what's
going on how weird that you can suit for
that and and you would think if that
happened you'd have a lot more lawsuits
from people way Beyond just the concert
goers but you'd have the venue you'd
have all the Ries you'd have all these
people that like are affected even more
than just people that didn't get home in
time also these International stars like
just to play Devil's Advocate sometimes
they're not even in that City for more
than the that concert so she could have
flown in that day or the flight was
delayed she was jetl yeah then she just
had to perform maybe she came in at like
I don't know 8 rushed to the venue
performed and has to bounce immediately
yeah cuz the door from her plane flew
out on that flight heard the whole thing
could be a setup just put it out there
so that you get into the news that
people are talking about it cuz did you
guys even know M was having a concert I
didn't now I know that's true you know
so that could be it too you know just
put it out there planted and all of a
sudden people are talking about you I
would still go to a Madonna concert she
yeah like I close my eyes and just think
of her young what's the most you pay
what you could just watch a DVD yeah
what's the most you pay to go see
Madonna like watching a DVD is weird too
though yeah I think YouTube got a DVD
player you wouldn't go see Madonna I
don't believe that bro I get VIP
everywhere I go okay my bad is she known
to like rock the [__] out of the shows
she actually has really um considerably
edgy type of like show material like
everything is very like almost looks
like slightly satanic a lot of
uhour like yeah I know we know know
choreographers you know what I mean uh
and they they do a lot of really like
edgy looking stuff you know dudes that
are shirtless carrying her out on like a
black that's always been her thing until
it was Gaga
y Dam everybody knows
that adding sanism into like concerts
addressing young people is so weird now
it's becom normalized it's like a right
now standard everything when you say it
like that that's funny well I mean
that's exactly what it is they know what
they're doing they're doing
intentionally but everyone's it's so
weird doat Sam Smith like everybody is
[__] little NX Sam Smith is doing
same stu oh he's one of the worst that
one I totally didn't see coming I didn't
even know that what was he what is he
doing oh yeah that was like way out yeah
but hey cool o can we really get
canceled oh I don't know if you guys are
not ready for this I'm ready I'm ready
for anything so like the worst one is
Taylor
Swift what's your oh you're saying
swifties are going to cancel us yeah oh
yeah you you don't want to feel the rat
though swifties yeah we don't but at the
same time H speaker truth freeth
thinker well she's been adding a lot of
Satanic ritual into her concert like
what stuff did she put what did she do
um she'll do like different witch
rituals she'll have different demons in
the crowd it's going way into there and
they it's a it's a show for teenage
girls why is everyone doing that yeah
what do you think that is it sells I I
think does it I think if you get really
deep I think there's a movement between
good and evil and this is a way that
people in the evil like promote their
product right cuz you want people to be
part of a ritual so there's a
ritualistic at aspect to what they do
you know and people who are on that
Charmed with my sister when I was
younger [__] s [__] freak and you
do it just like as a fun thing now you
have thousands of people participating
in these ritualistic Jour ritualistic
processes together which is literally
what a ritual is so they are having
these Satanic rituals and having
everyone be a part of it which is kind
of a scary thing is that why we all
[__] love Harry Potter and [__]
everybody so I don't like that [__]
speak for yourself like I actually don't
like it either I mean that that was like
like
it
for don't point that [__] Wanda at me
boy the ride was cool I like all that
[__] cuz it looks funny All or Nothing
dude you got to like it or not so have
you guys seen the picture of Taylor
Swift and the satanic Priestess no let
me see I need to see some of this bro
are you serious I'm not I don't really
follow Taylor Swift stuff I hate her
music I haven't been to her concert you
hate her music that's messed up look
I'll say this her tiny desk is hella
good look she's a great artist bro she's
a great writer every song she plays I'm
like oh I've heard this song before this
is really catchy but at the end of the
day I'm like I know this is just not for
me you don't seem like a Swifty kind of
take that [__] back take that [__]
back y z Le is the daughter to the
founder of the satanic Church what's
that guy's name again I don't remember
his name I'm guessing Mr LA but his
daughter Zena La was really big into
music was really she had a certain look
about her little saty and then then you
have Taylor Swift who used to be like
this country girl like really cute and
pretty and whatever let's see the
reveal wow yeah it's uncanny that kind
of gave me a little chills I don't like
that it's a little bit of a stretch no
no but also they're just white yeah
that's also true that's also true white
people be like similar but what is that
what do you mean by Satan I don't see
the Satan is no no no she's mimicking
the Satan's daughter yeah if you go
super far conspiracy far conspiracy
anywh super far
conspiracy I'll throw out the disclaimer
that he's technically not a formally
Associated member of the JK no you guys
you guys this is conspiracy for the sake
of conspiracy fun this is just fun sick
yeah there are theories that there are
actually clones of people in the world
yeah okay right like Joe Biden isn't Joe
Biden he's a clone yeah right like he's
wearing a mask like Jamie Fox somehow
passed and now we have the Clone version
of Jamie Fox right make let's see if he
could that Taylor Swift is actually a
clone of Zena Le oh the
Priestess these are the crazy
conspiracies out there can was Zena Le
able to sing though like a God can
Taylor Swift Swing Swing Swing can
Taylor Swift sing I mean sorry Swifty
yeah she's fantastic she's amazing you
have to be a pretty good artist to be
able to sell a good ritual yeah that's
true it's a good vehicle yeah you can't
really I mean if you take the conspiracy
thought of it and you just take it as
what it is what is that and
baby that you have Satanic rituals that
really do exist in the world right that
there are people that really worship
evil over worship good that if you
actually believe this stuff then this
stuff isn't actually that crazy what
kind of Satan [__] is like right in
front of our noses that we wouldn't
really notice cuz I feel like I'm the
guy that's like goes right over
Jiu-Jitsu have you guys shut up dude
have you guys watched the Obama movie on
Netflix no I Obama movie no he got a
movie dude you guys need to watch the
one that he produced yes he was
executive producer of a movie called I
think the world is not done or the world
is over or whatever it is can you look
up the name the end of times thing right
the world is a the world is a
vampire that is one is that jelly roll
is that t Swift I like the idea that
somewhere out there there's this artist
who's massive Satan worshipper trying to
do these rituals but he just sucks at
singing he just can't get traction so
everybody's like
Leave the World
Behind oh that's his that's Obama oh
[__] so Obama left office and he he's
got more money than God right Obama is a
rich rich man yeah and what he decided
to do was he's going to start a
production company and he's going to
make a movie and the movie and his first
movie that he ever is going to produce
and put his name on literally in the
credit says executive producers Barack
and Michelle Obama wow the first movie
they make is this a dystopian movie
about how technology will fail us how
we're going to be under attack and how
the world is going to end that's the
first movie this guy makes crazy right
in the opening credits is ridiculous
amount of satanic
imagery just off the bat off the bat
what is it like [__] goat heads and
[__] so one of the first opening scenes
there is a scene where they show a bed
next to it is a clock pointing at six a
mug next to it pointing at 6 and the
other side another clock pointing at six
it's a imagery with a pattern and the
only numbers you see are 6 6 six oh my
God that's intentional why would you do
that on purpose cuz it's Satan of course
but why happens to be 6:00 I don't know
but why do you put all three of them at
6 like if it was one six it's by chance
when you produced movie you guys know
everything is intentional yeah mm why
would you do that and these types of
imagery is throughout the entire movie
yeah it's weird it's almost like they're
telling you what is going to happen in
the world next they're almost projecting
the plan because in the idea of Satanism
right is that you have to tell what
you're going to do before you do it
because otherwise it's not promoting
their would their goal and it's not part
of their plan oh so when you see these
imagery things that's them making like a
declaration correct to make it effective
exactly that's that's how Satan ISM
works if you don't say it before you do
it it's actually not effective calling
side pocket before you have to call it
before you do it call your shot it's way
more impressive that way so they put all
these imageries out there almost letting
you know they're going to do it which is
like the craziest part of it right like
these things happen in real life and we
see it every day and we notice it but we
don't notice it they hide it within like
the imagery and we consume it every
single day of our lives and this going
to make me sound so
crazy right but once you start seeing
them like you start seeing them
everywhere you're like [__] they're
doing this [__]
intentionally and that's really
concerning but it's not just seeing them
it's also hearing
it well now you're demonetized what is
this now see he didn't know what it was
I can't read it I thought it was Barack
Obama's
[Music]
song